I love the movie I love Star Trek into
darkness thought it was fantastic and
you know just now what's you just come
out here you're so confident you're so
radiant were you as it as a youngster
did you know that you want to be a
performer did you have that that's kind
of confidence I did know I guess I was a
little bit of an exhibitionist you know
I had two younger brothers so obviously
I had to organize that battalion and uh
I guess I did know how are you an
exhibitionist you said you just like you
like to get attention anyway he said
something once that's gonna stay with me
I used to lift up my skirt and I feel
like as a three-year-old though I mean
it's hot it's like a child thing to do
and it's uh she was three shut up you
know back when I was you know 21 it
stopped by then were you did you get in
trouble a lot in school were you sort of
a bold a bold youngster would you say I
did get in trouble a lot in school I did
I as much as I enjoyed school I suppose
I didn't see the point of it at the same
time so that was a little bit of a
stress for me I but again that kind of
gave me I think an impetus to move
forward I had a math teacher who told me
that with a brain like mine I'd really
better leave school now and kidding
really
no I thought that's what I thought that
when she said it I thought you're
kidding so I sort of decided I think
she's the reason that I even did all
right in school at all because after
that I decided to work and I got into
University and you went to Oxford again
I remember correctly that was one of the
greatest schools in the world yeah but
this was this like abusive math teacher
I had who told me that I was never gonna
do anything and I felt well she was
actually called miss mould miss mould
that's like a Harry Potter teacher did
well what did you do that annoyed her so
much were you just not doing your work
or actively trying to cause trouble
turned her back was my fault when she
turned her back we used to go down in
the chair and like dude literally do
like simulate sex this is awful for me
this is this situation wait a minute I
feel like you're having sex you go like
this cuz I do that too
whole another like me I was gonna say so
that's what Queen Elizabeth is doing
[Applause]
yeah you know we won't even bring up the
sound I think we thought she was an
alien and we'd be like doo doo doo doo
you start having what is essentially
chair yeah Ellison